Sandra good morning good to see you
morning oh my gosh we were all oohing
and high I took pictures of all of us
oohing and eyeing over these items let's
begin with the crown talk to me about it
this is the iconic Freddie Mercury item
this is a crown that he designed with
Dana Mosley a costume designer and a
close friend of his it was worn during
his last live performance with Queen in
1986 I mean this is indelibly linked
with Freddy the crown idea I mean if you
see this Cartier Broach that I'm wearing
which was Freddy's it says Queen number
one
Freddie designed that crown logo himself
so this is very much something that he
came up with the concept for it very I
love that we have it on video and we're
not allowed to touch it but yes believe
me we wanted to touch it it's very heavy
is it very it's very lightweight it's
very very lightweight this we're fat
we're doing an eyeing about the lyrics
because you've got we are We Are the
Champions here yes we are the champions
and uh Bohemian Rhapsody where it's
crossed out where he had an alternative
title what is it it was originally
Mongolian Rhapsody wow same numbers yes
same syllables exactly but not quite the
same feeling no so you can see he
scratched that out the most important
line to him you can see he starts off
with nothing really matters Voice
singing that lunch I can totally I can
hear his voice singing so powerful he
seems to have written it on a piece of
like scheduling paper at an airline that
doesn't exist anymore British Midland
Airways the things you can accomplish uh
if you don't have a phone in your hand I
guess right he must have been bored he
had a couple documents they just started
writing and he's got the operatic
section yes too he's putting a little
section here middle section Opera high
low I mean what you're seeing here
essentially is his idea coming to
fruition it's Coral motifs it's piano
balladri it's the operatic uh part of it
it's hard rock all of those motifs
playing it into this one song and it's
15 pages we can't see here but it's 15
pages 15 pages long and you can see he
planned it out as a long story arc he
wanted it to be all of these sections
Cassandra this jacket number one he's
little yeah
you could not wear it no me neither and
I'm a girl I think you guys could wear
oh what I don't but tell us about the
jacket we've seen this too yeah so this
is an iconic jacket that he wore for
many live performances over a three to
four year period including on Saturday
Night Live in 1982 and this was the last
live performance he did in the US I'm
going to turn the jacket around so you
can see this amazing design on the back
wow you really can't put a dollar amount
on what you hope this will bring right
no it's very difficult this has never
been done before these are unique items
we can put estimates you know the
estimate for this is 20 to 30 000 pounds
the lyrics uh Bohemian Rhapsody the
estimates 800 000 to 1.2 million pounds
wow 200 to 300 what is the crown forty
thousand to sixty thousand pounds I
think you may get that and more I think
so we sold Biggie's crown for six
hundred thousand dollars at Sotheby's a
couple years ago so well somebody knows
what they're doing ahead of Pop Culture
yes title in the world thank you very
much thank you no thank you for bringing
and sharing it with us this morning
thank you so much thank you